the state department has an important
message for
the people of the earth
and here's the message they tweeted out
yesterday
it says today on international pronouns
day
we share why many people list pronouns
on their email and social media profiles
read more here and then
if you click and it goes to
share.america.gov
so this is a government website
shared by the state department
and uh there's a whole article about
about pronouns
it says i'll read some of it it says in
the united states it's becoming
increasingly common for people to share
their pronouns third person personal
pronouns are used to describe a person
or people in english american grammar as
the subject as the object or the
possessive
these pronouns include the
gender-neutral they them theirs words
that traditionally refer to a plural
number but that today are used by some
individuals who identify as gender
non-binary or who prefer not to share
gender information
other pronouns include the feminine she
her hers and the masculine he him his
some people are pioneering
gender-neutral pronouns such as
zee-zer-zers
this is a government website this is the
state department
putting zur zurs
out into the world officially endorsing
it
um
and then i don't need to keep reading
this i can't keep reading it i'll have
all my i'll have an aneurism if i do
i have to tell you when i when i
when i encounter this kind of this kind
of thing
of course my first reaction is just
sheer embarrassment
that this is the u.s state department
ostensibly supposed to represent us
represent the united states of america
and this is what they're exporting out
into the world and this is what this is
this is this is a
an intentional
act i mean this goes beyond merely
pandering to the left
this is the religion that our government
right now is exporting into the world
this is the ideology
it's a religion of self-creation of
self-worship
um
a religion that rejects truth as a
category
rejects truth as a category
not just has a different idea about
truth or has a different idea about what
is true and what isn't
but rejects it as a tragic as a category
there is no truth
what is truth as pontius pilate said
it's in a way is the punches pilot
religion
now what is truth the truth is whatever
you make whatever you decide that it is
and this is what the united states of
america this is what they want the
united states of america to represent
on earth
we used to talk about how we wanted the
us to represent freedom to all the
peoples of the earth perhaps we should
have been more specific
because now we represent freedom from
reality
freedom from truth freedom from moral
decency
freedom from even biological realities
biological science
freedom from our own bodies
that's what we represent but
when i see this along with feeling
embarrassed
i also can't can't help but uh every
time i it makes me mad
and angry
at the right
i mean yeah at the left but it's
it's it's fruitless it's pointless it's
redundant at this point to be angry at
the left of course i am but
even more so at the right
because
maybe ultimately there was there was
nothing we could have done about about
this about this this slide into madness
even if we had all been on the ball
about it from the beginning
it may have still ended up this way i
don't know
but the fact is that so many people on
the right for years were just whistling
past the graveyard with this stuff
and they would say about the pronoun
issue oh it's just who cares about that
just call people what they want why why
are you so focused on this why are you
talking about it this is a small issue
this is a sideshow this is a distraction
for years and years that's what i heard
i don't hear it anymore
i mean i've been on these issues as you
know
from day one
and for years
the criticism i would get from people on
the right is this these issues don't
matter it does it doesn't make a
difference it's this is superficial
this is a phase it'll go away why are
you why are you paying attention to it
just don't pay attention to it and it'll
go away
right like jurassic park with the t-rex
don't move it its vision is based on
movement stand there still and it will
walk past you
for years that's what i heard
and i don't hear it anymore
because even the dumbest most clueless
most oblivious
uh muddled brained people on the right
even they
even those even the ones in that
category are starting to see that oh wow
this is a big deal
this is a war on truth
i mean we are marching into total lunacy
and madness
and there is no end in sight and it oh
it actually matters who who would have
thought
but it's kind of too late now
like if this is your wake-up call that
the state department
is celebrating international pronouns
day
and talking about z zimzers
you know if you thought this was a phase
and it would just go away it's a silly
childhood thing and it would you know
and now and now the state department
is promoting it and if this is your
wake-up call we'll say it's too late if
you enjoyed this video be sure to give
it a thumbs up and share it with all
your friends